when we put together all five of the
criteria in smart
we end up with compelling and direct
objectives
but that's not the whole story now that
you're equipped with a concrete
definition of smart
here are a few best practices to
consider when setting your own goals
first create goals that reflect your
unique needs
smart goals are only as good as the kpis
you set
not all business needs are the same even
within the same industry
choosing kpis that don't reflect your
business goals
just because someone else is using them
or a post on the internet tells you to
can send you in the wrong direction
while we do talk at length about certain
metrics to avoid
you should always carefully consider
what makes the most sense for your
personal or business needs
second use smart as a form of
communication and transparency
like any form of communication having
clear information helps teams and
managers act upon it better
smart is meant to help provide a way to
communicate exactly where you are
and how well you're doing when everyone
in the business understands the goals
and criteria to reach them
they can work together to succeed
third carefully plan the best route and
check in along the way
it's a great idea to plan the order of
operations and the order of achievements
that will help you best reach long-term
goals
because smart emphasizes specific and
bite-sized goals
you're likely to have a series of goals
some goals will be in flight
simultaneously
and some will be dependent on the
success of other goals
use historical data to help anticipate
issues along the way and plan for
check-in milestones to adjust kpis
if you have a goal that is time-bound to
a year you might plan to check in each
quarter
much like using a gps check-ins can help
tell you if you're veering off track
fourth remember that smart isn't just
for large company or team goals
smart is a set of criteria most often
cited as an incredibly useful way to set
and track business objectives and
metrics
but they also work well on the personal
level
feel empowered to use the smart criteria
for or as
an individual or small team when
employees can track how well they're
performing with great goals and metrics
they can better see how their
performance will directly impact the
organization's performance on the larger
scale
or if you'd like consider using smart
outside of a business context entirely
there's nothing stopping you from
applying this knowledge to a new year's
resolution
fitness goal job search home improvement
project
or anything else finally
understand that smart only works if the
long-term strategy is good
it is important to also acknowledge that
smart has two distinct flaws
first smart breaks down a larger
strategy into small
digestible and achievable parts if the
overall strategy or vision is rotten
then smart will only help you achieve
the goals that poor strategy dictates
second smart is a method of setting
goals
not a way to analyze successes and
failures
when setting goals be sure to build in
time to make your goal setting process
smarter by including the
self-explanatory evaluate and reduce
stages
always keep an eye on ways to design
your next smart goals better than your
last goals
when you evaluate think about what
pitfalls popped up
about questions you should have asked
people who should have been involved
and so on at the end of the day smart is
just a set of criteria
and set of considerations it's up to us
to reflect on our methods in order to
set better and better goals